gone through three hours of makeup and
then stand in front of the mirror and
see yourself transformed
for some acting in a harry potter movie
sounds like a dream come true
but when you realize how incredibly
uncomfortable some of the makeup effects
were
it might make things seem a little less
appealing
from transforming humans into gringotts
goblins
to the hours of makeup to bring
voldemort to life and even a giant body
double for hagrid
some of the most iconic harry potter
makeup transformations
were seriously painful for the actors
underneath it all
i've had prosthetics on before and it's
like it can be tough it can be like hard
work
for the second task in the goblet of
fire harry had to eat gillyweed and grow
gills so he could swim into the black
lake
which you might assume would all be done
with cgi
but nope they actually did it for real
the gills were made out of silicone and
silk
so that they would billow underwater
they had to be glued onto daniel
radcliffe's neck
so firmly so that they would stay put
during the long underwater filming
process
and also during the harrowing scene
where he had to swim to the surface
carrying two heavy life-like dolls of
ron and gabrielle de la cour
in the end daniel said that he was
really proud that he made it through
good god who's that really robbie
coltrane who plays hagrid
is tall but not giant tall
in order to transform him into the half
giant hagrid they gave him risers in his
shoes
and padded him with heavy costumes extra
wigs and prosthetics to make him appear
larger
but they also brought in a 6'4 body
double for wide shots
who had to wear some massive padding and
a prosthetic animatronic hagrid head
because the costume was so huge and
heavy they actually attached tubes that
pumped cold water
into it so the body double didn't
overheat and pass out
the embarrassment of seeing yourself 18
feet high in front of a lot of people
you don't know
in order to transform human actors into
gringotts goblins
the makeup team started their work at
4am
they created molds of each actor's face
and created a combination of rubber
masks
and individual prosthetic parts to
attach one by one
the actors also had to have their hands
covered with extensive makeup and
prosthetic pieces
long fake fingernails and dentures to
finish off the look
each goblin took four hours to get ready
and they even wore
contact lenses that obscured their
vision so much that they needed
chaperones to help get them around the
set on this one we're doing 45
full prosthetic makeups british actor
warwick davis
not only played professor flitwick the
first goblin bank teller but
also grip hook in the harry potter
series very unusual was it
to make sure he was unrecognizable from
one character to the next
it took hours and hours in the makeup
chair first
they created a cast of his face which
involved sitting under
layers of silicone and plaster for hours
and only his nose holes free to breathe
once the prosthetic pieces for grip hook
were applied warwick said he had to
re-learn how to use his face
underneath all those extra layers and
totally adjust his voice to speak
through the false teeth
hello ready for the office in order to
make the actor who play dumbledore's
brother aberforth look as much like
michael gambin as possible
they used a lot of makeup and extensive
wigs
the makeup crew added silicone to his
forehead and face
to push back his hairline applied
prosthetic bags under his eyes
completely changed his eyebrows and of
course added his long hair and beard to
finish off the look
it was quite interesting because in a
way you're working on a
blank canvas even though you might think
it was cgi
the scene in which harry accidentally
blows up his aunt marge
was all done in camera it took 20 people
to build and apply the inflatable suit
to pam ferris
the actress who played ant marge and
included pumps
de-gassing chambers and inflatable
bladders
they even created a balloon shaped and
painted like her face
attached it to her body and pumped it
full of air to give the effect of her
face inflating
to film professor lupin turning into a
werewolf they created each step of the
transformation on the actor david thulis
with prosthetic makeup before adding cgi
in post
the makeup team wanted to avoid the
cliche werewolf transformation
so they focused on changing his eyes and
bringing out the two huge scars across
his face with makeup and silicone
each step of the transformation took six
hours to complete
and they actually built fake moving body
parts that were attached to david so
they could capture as much as possible
in camera
that turned out not to be practical much
to my relief because it looked really
very uncomfortable to do that when it
came to peter pettigrew
the makeup team tried hard to connect
the human version of pettigrew to
scabbers the rat through his hair
skin texture and hands the actor sat for
hours in the makeup chair as they added
the gray balding wig
browning teeth dirty pointy nails and
skin texture until he was almost
entirely covered in makeup and itchy
fake hair
it's a horrible profession but i think
you should be an actor
even though we might not realize it
lucius malfoy undergoes a serious change
over the course of the harry potter
movies
the actor said he went from a simple
natural look and wig application
to a lot more time in the makeup trailer
they added prosthetic bags under his
eyes
and very heavy pale makeup to make him
look as
tired and unhealthy as the character
needed to be the eighth film has become
a shadow of his former self
if polyjuice potion were a real thing it
would be much
easier than what brendan gleeson went
through to become mad eye moody
they spent hours adding an entire layer
of skin over his real face
to build the eye and its holder into in
order to make it look like it was
embedded in his face
they covered his real eye in tape and
added the bulging glass eye over it
so for the entire shoot he could only
see out of one eye
the magical eye was radio controlled by
a crew member who made it swivel around
but sometimes it would actually pop out
sponged the transfers onto my scalp and
face
seeing voldemort for the first time was
a huge undertaking because of how
enormous the fans expectations were for
that exact moment
in order to transform the handsome ray
finds
into the dark lord they used a
combination of makeup
and prosthetics the process took hours
but luckily he only had to do the full
transformation about 60 to 70 times
throughout the whole series
and about 50 of those times were for the
last two movies
rafe still wanted to be able to act
under it all so they covered his
eyebrows
reshaped his eyes added long creepy
fingernails and false teeth
but the transformation wasn't complete
until they removed his nose using cgi
sort of slightly translucent
vein like quality we all remember the
scene where harry breaks his arm playing
quidditch
and gilda roy lockhart comes along to
fix it but ends up removing all the
bones instead
well that wobbly boneless arm wasn't cgi
at all but was actually a prosthetic
that they actually
attached to the real daniel radcliffe
and guess what
he still has it along with a few pairs
of potter glasses
daniel said that he has that creepy fake
arm sitting in his attic
all these years later i don't seek them
out
when creating professor trelawny emma
thompson had the idea that
since she is always looking into the
future the divination teacher can't
really see where she is in the present
so they came up with her famous coke
bottle glasses
while they were perfect for making her
eyes look very funny and large
they were actually quite uncomfortable
as they magnified
everything around her you must look
beyond
for the enormous battle at hogwarts the
makeup team worked overtime to apply
fake blood
and wounds to the literally hundreds of
actors and background performers
playing the students and members of
dumbledore's army the actors
especially matthew lewis who played
neville longbottom had to wear itchy
uncomfortable fake blood and silicone
prosthetic wounds
for days on end during filming which got
very tiresome in the end
which was great to start with you know
blood and cuts and bruises
and it takes like two hours to transform
the very young
very famous actors into older versions
of themselves
it required lots of prosthetics and
makeup but
not too much according to the crew the
first old age test made ron
look about 75 years old and seriously
unhealthy
eventually they found a good balance did
it work
well that's for you to decide who knew
that so much of harry potter was
actually done for real
even though it wasn't comfortable we're
sure that all of these actors are proud
of their hard work
especially daniel radcliffe and those
crazy underwater scenes
thanks for watching